hello
now when you look at me right now you
probably think that it's me sal talking
to you
but really what is talking to you
is a society of over 30 trillion cells
that have somehow collectively convinced
itself that it is sal and what we're
going to study in these lessons are
exactly that
that even though we think we're one
unified organism where frankly all the
living things we see are that we say oh
that's a plant and that's a frog and
that's a pigeon and that's a cell
it's not just a cell it's made up of
trillions and trillions of things called
cells which well as we'll learn they're
the fundamental building blocks of life
what makes them alive and if we were to
go at a at an even more basic scale all
of a sudden things are not alive it's a
fascinating philosophical question and
you might think that one 30 trillionth
of me might might be some kind of small
simple thing but as we'll see there's a
whole universe in each cell unimaginable
complexity that scientists are still
trying to understand in these lessons
we're going to talk about the history of
mankind trying to struggle with the
basic units of life is there a basic
unit and and how do we how do we
understand how it works also known as
cell theory we're going to learn about
the different types of cells that even
exist things like prokaryotic and
eukaryotic cells things like plant and
animal cells what's similar what's
different and finally we're going to
learn about parts of the cell especially
things like say the membrane which in
and of itself is a fascinating and
complex piece of machinery so we're
about to delve into some of the deepest
ideas that mankind has always faced what
is life what makes one thing alive and
another thing not alive what is the most
basic unit of life where did it come
from we're going to touch on all of
those in the next few lessons
and i encourage you if you want to dive
deeper and get more context and get
practice to make sure that you're
understanding these concepts look at
these lessons on khan academy.org